háblenos un poco entonces delegado
musical que dejó Pablo Milanés un gusto
estar con ustedes hoy aquí en francés 24
eh Pablo Milanés no solamente es una
gran voz No Solamente fue una gran voz
un gran intérprete de las voces más
Versátiles que tenía la nueva Trova
cubana sino también Es realmente el
iniciador del movimiento de la nueva
Trova cubana él parte en dos Esa esa
historia porque es el vínculo entre el
feeling el feeling cubano tan tan
apegado a ese Sony a ese a ese bolero de
antaño de La Isla con el movimiento de
la nueva Trova cubana su canción mis 22
años es la primera canción que se que se
conoce del movimiento de la nueva Trova
cubana Entonces es es mucho más que una
una gran voz versátil una pluma
deliciosa y alguien que que logra
vincular la música con la poesía porque
musicalizó de manera muy afortunada a
grandes
escritores de nuestra de nuestra lengua
vínculo la música con la poesía y
también con la política alguna manera
Pero cuál fue digamos su impacto en la
música de La isla y también en los
movimientos sociales de Cuba
pues total el impacto de Pablo Milanés
en la política en la música y en la
poesía ese absolutamente
generoso creo que se desmarcó totalmente
de del movimiento revolucionario hace un
par de años cuando decide radicarse por
cuestiones de salud Porque desde hace
mucho tiempo padecía una osteoporosis
que que no le permitía dar conciertos de
pie por ejemplo Esa era la razón
fundamental por la que no cantaba de pie
siempre siempre estaba sentado y Desde
allí empezó a desvincularse con el
movimiento revolucionario de su país al
que apoyó de manera contundente en los
60 en los 70 haciendo una una voz
artística muy activa y políticamente
también muy activa con otros personajes
como como Noé Nicola como Vicente feliú
como Silvio Rodríguez
un poquito más tarde como con Sara
González en fin creo que que la
importancia de Pablo Milanés dentro del
entorno musical de La Isla es absoluto
pero no solamente eso también es muy
importante para nuestra música
latinoamericana ese disco querido Pablo
por ejemplo en el que participan en
grandes exponentes de lo que se denominó
en algún momento como la nueva canción
otros llamaban canción protex canción
protesta pero también esa canción Dejó
de ser protesta porque no solamente
hacía referencia a la radiografía
política sino también abordada temas
temas de en los temas del amor como como
bien lo mencionaste hace un rato como
Yolanda por ejemplo más adelante le
compuso a Sandra en fin entonces creo
que que su importancia tanto en el
aspecto político que como digo se
desvinculó bastante Claro en los últimos
años como en el artístico fue
fundamental